[Music]
what up guys this goes on here for anime
uproar today we're talking about who the
strongest titan is and in order to talk
about this we will have to get into
manga spoilers so if you haven't read
the manga get reading you won't regret
it I promise if you're new to this
channel be sure to subscribe for more
attack on Titan and other anime related
videos I just want to thank everyone for
the great response into every Titan
explained video and it was actually
answered that video that the question
came up who is the strongest Titan
currently answering this question is not
as simple or straightforward as you
might think at first glance obviously
according to legend amir fritz made a
deal with the devil and became the first
and strongest titan after she died her
powers were split between nine titans
the attack titan armored Titan colossal
titan female titan beast titan sounding
titan jaws Cartman and an unknown ninth
Titan that has yet to be introduced out
of these Titans all have their strengths
and weaknesses if you want to see an
explanation of each be sure to check out
that every Titan explained video that
I'll link in the description
some like jaws and Cartman are very
useful in their own ways but are clearly
not as strong as the others even brute
power alone does not necessarily make a
Titan the strongest in my opinion we can
look at these statistics that were
released in the official guidebook for
attack on Titan if we go by this
information Colossus would be the
strongest with an off-the-charts rating
of 11 for power armor Titan would be
second with 8 the beast Titan would be
third with 7 and the female Titan would
be 4 foot 6
however this ordering fails to take into
account the Colossus slow speed or
bertolt personality the possessor of the
Titan power is actually very important
to consider when we are determining who
is the strongest Titan while bertolt
appears slack confidence and
decision-making skills Zeke the control
of the beast Titans does not Zeke has
great leadership qualities he can be
completely ruthless when the situation
calls for it and is extremely
intelligent not to mention his other
special abilities which allow him to
create and control other Titans even by
moonlight his control although not
perfect rivals the power of the founding
Titan in addition he is strong enough to
rip out chunks of the wall and able to
accurately hit targets from an
unbelievable distance his intelligence
scores are also off the charts
tying attack on Titans resident mad
scientist grungy and although the
armored Titan is supposed to be the more
powerful one the beast Titan destroys
him effortlessly when Raynor tries to
prioritize rescuing Annie over acquiring
the coordinate the power of the founding
Titan that is currently in Aaron Raynor
even calls the their strongest soldiers
which further lends weight to the
argument that the beast Titan is
currently the strongest Titan in theory
the founding Titan should be the
strongest but that power lies dormant in
Aaron currently although he has used the
power of the coordinate before when he
came into contact with Tina fritz
he cannot usually access this power and
although Aaron's potential is great he
still has a long way to go until his
control of the attack and founding Titan
can match up against these power however
that potential is there especially if
they can find a way for Aaron to
maintain contact with royal blood for
extended periods of time perhaps they
could inject Aaron with Historians blood
or something like that we will see what
happens but the fact is that Zeke's time
is running out because of Amir's curse
he has less than a year to go before he
must give up his power supposedly to the
warrior cadet Colt but as Colt has noted
other possessors did not share Zeke's
Titan creating ability probably because
they were not of royal blood it is also
important to consider that as a whole
the power of the Titans is beginning to
be eclipsed during the return of the
chigan Sheena art Levi destroys the
Beast Titan Zeke would have been killed
a fellow warrior piak did not rescue him
in her Titan form in the nick of time
furthermore at the Battle of Fort Slava
the beast Titan was almost killed by
anti Titan artillery once again he would
have died but was saved by Raynor who
despite his armor suffered extreme
injuries after the battle Marlay a fish
acknowledge that the power of technology
has practically caught up with the power
of the Titans and will inevitably
surpass it soon as of now the Beast
Titan is the strongest but that might
change if Eren learns to better control
his Titan powers if the ninth Titan
proves to be even stronger than Zeek or
when Zeek eventually died whatever way
you look at it though it appears that
Titan powers in general are no longer as
formidable as they once were anyways
guys that's it for this video thanks for
watching and let me know who you think
the strongest Titan is in the comments
section below if you enjoyed this video
be sure to go beast mode on that like
button and subscribe for more videos
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]